if you just can't wait for all the
upcoming batman related projects
starting next year here are five titles
worth checking out in the meantime
on this week's bench guide along with
the release of the batman in theaters
october 2021
a new spin-off series gotham pd will be
coming to hbo max at some point as well
luckily there's a whole batcave full of
options to binge if you want to get more
acquainted with bruce and all of his
well
acquaintances and from animated to live
action and old to new this list has got
you covered starting with our editor's
pick and my favorite animated show of
all time
batman beyond this animated show about
bruce wayne training a new batman for
the 21st century ran on the wb remember
that
from 1999 to 2000 with two of three
seasons coming in 100
fresh on the tomato meter this show came
from the same people who brought us the
emmy-winning batman the animated series
in the early 90s with one critic calling
it an
excellent and underappreciated series
that shows batman in a whole new light
you can binge this show in about 20
hours but when you're done you should be
totally trained
as the next batman i think that's how it
works next up is our certified fresh
pick
gotham this show ran for five fresh
seasons two of them certified fresh from
2014 to 2018 and it follows a young
detective james gordon
and serves as an origin story for all
kinds of super villains and vigilantes
including some kid who will eventually
grow up to dress like a bat
star ben mckenzie is surrounded by a
talented cast making up what critics say
is a dense roster of colorful villains
in an appealingly stylized approach to
the batman mythos
it'll take you 70 hours to finish all
100 episodes of this series but at least
you'll know that detective gordon does
eventually get a promotion next up is
our brand new pick and that's going to
the animated series harley quinn
the second straight fresh season of this
show wrapped up on dc universe earlier
this year and it follows the longtime
nemesis of batman after she breaks up
with the joker and heads out on her own
along with kaylee cuoco as harley the
stacked voice cast
includes lake bell tony hale jb smoove
john carlos vozito
and dedrick bader voicing batman himself
just to name a few
and critics call this a violently
delightful and surprisingly insightful
addition to the dc
animated universe after binging this one
in just under 10 hours you can toss out
a few harley quinn cuss words about the
fact that season 3 has not yet been
picked up
and for our throwback pick this week we
are throwing it all the way back to 1966
to the original batman tv series
this classic starring adam west and burt
ward ran for 120 episodes over three
years
and has lived on for decades in
syndication and while the campiness and
lighter tone is much different than the
more recent iterations of batman
critics say it's now lauded as a
timeless satire of the comics canon
it also loki had one of the coolest
batmobiles ever
you can bench this series in 50 hours
and holy fight scenes batman you're
gonna love how they used to throw down
with bad guys
zap pow and bang and finally at your
service with our audience pick this week
is the epic series pennyworth this show
follows bruce wayne's butler
alfred pennyworth a former special
forces soldier who goes to work with
thomas wayne in 1960s london
now critics say that while it doesn't
add much to the greater batman mythos
the intriguing characters and impressive
set pieces make for an engaging spy
thriller and with an audience score of
95 percent the fans are clearly into it
season two is in the works but no word
on a release date yet so until then you
can binge season one
in about 20 hours all right bat fans
hopefully this will make your next few
bench sessions battastic be sure to let
us know what you are currently streaming
in the comments
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future recommendations based around the
movies and shows that you love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell
as always we can't thank you enough for
watching binge guide right here on
rotten tomatoes and we'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you